from the National Review Secret Service
found marijuana twice at the White House
in 2022
okay I mean does that bother it's legal
there right well not inside the Federal
Building no but like
at what point do we say come on
it depends on if it was like Edibles or
if it was uh
we know I I
someone just needs to
Joe can you ask your son just maybe no
if he's gonna if he's gonna smoke body
you know if it's gonna be him like can
you just clean it up and just not get
caught I really don't think that uh
Hunter Biden is smoking much weed
personally I really think that it's that
it's amphetamines I think that it's
cocaine maybe but I mean if if he is if
he was getting off of that stuff man I
wouldn't be surprised if he was like
well this one's not so bad sometimes
it's also funnier than maybe Joe's just
not senile and old maybe he's just super
stoned all the time that would be that's
actually a way funnier story no because
if that was the case then he would have
actually descheduled it like he said he
was going to do instead of just waving
it off and it never happened first thing
he does in office is make it legal so he
can have it right there right I mean the
executive order is the way uh the way I
would have rolled as president like
Hunter you're free baby I think they're
trying to plant it on Biden and he just
keeps
right so they're like we got to get them
out there's no chance in 24 so they keep
getting all these different drugs hoping
that secret service will find it on him
but Biden's just not with it so he just
keeps leaving it places like outside the
Situation Room they're like we really
don't know who it belongs to because
it's Joe's hunter gets a coffee thing
here right maybe you get Joe your coffee
and uh he'll wake up I just gotta say
you know our coffee is the best coffee
Appalachian nights the best coffee
everyone agrees if Joe had that coffee
right now the country being a way better
way better way better way Afghanistan
would have been Flawless
maybe that's the commercial we do we
have like you see Joe Biden but only
from from behind and he's like stumbling
and we saw all the clips of him stomach
falling and then it's like people in
suits being like quick quick and they
pull the bag of Casper coffee and then
you see Biden stumble in and there's
like a camera shaking and he grabs the
coffee sips it and all sudden stands up
right and he's like I'm ready man fixes
him fixes him right up perfect yeah I
think you should or we can do one where
someone keep like Ian travels back in
time and keeps pouring a glass of Casper
coffee for Joe right before these major
moments and then everything just goes
right
it's like preparing for the Afghan
withdrawal and then Ian's just like
pouring the cup of coffee and he slides
it out there
saving the world one cup of Casper at a
time
right before the debates
you know in all seriousness serious
seriousness though
I don't really care for a pot I'm not a
fan of it I think it's very bad for
people I think a lot of people are like
ah it's no big deal it should be legal
and all this stuff and I'm like well
okay I'm fairly libertarian on stuff I
don't care what you do with your life
but I think wheat is pretty bad for you
I think to all the people I knew growing
up growing up and you know the ones that
were smoking pot all the time did not do
nearly as well as the ones who did not
and so you know whatever I think that's
why you say actually South Park said it
the best Randy Marsh said son it's not
that it's gonna kill you or do any
things to you it's that it makes you
okay with being bored and then when
you're older you'll find you're not good
at anything so that's a reason why you
shouldn't do he's like okay thanks Dad
but uh that being said it is not legally
allowed in the white house and there is
a drug problem in the white house right
now and I I have questions you know we
talk about a two or three tier justice
system
come on man
come on oh there's at least three tiers
there's the the broken the knot broke
yeah right and then and then you can
talk about the whether Trump's on a
different level than Biden or whatever
but yeah I'm not included in any of that
uh and I I'm supposed to have white
privilege yeah right so uh they'll throw
my ass in jail quick I think it's a
major problem like it's one thing to do
drugs and know about it in the white
house it's another thing to constantly
leave them everywhere
they're not very good I mean Nixon
didn't leave his all over the place
yeah
at least you know at least clean up
after yourself there's no cameras in the
White House apparently either the Secret
Service said oh we couldn't figure out
whose cocaine that was so I was
surprised to hear that considering all
the cameras I see in every Federal
Building I've ever worked in I wasn't
surprised to hear it it's the bidens
the the Secret Service was like
Ben Shapiro pointed this out that uh the
Secret Service reportedly went to the
gun shop where Hunter bought his gun and
that was illegally disposed of and tried
to collect records seemingly to protect
the bidens from Criminal prosecution now
I gotta tell you as a Libertarian
that's the most base thing I ever heard
right Hunter being charged with
marijuana and a gun charge second
amendment that that's dope right I I you
know I gotta say
I don't think Hunter Biden should be
charged for owning a weapon there's but
there there's an a fair argument through
due process you can't have your rights
curtailed that's what prison literally
is and if you are found to be a drug
user and we've determined that to be
like hey you know through due process
we've determined you do not have this
right I think there's questions about
whether that should or should be laws or
not that because someone smoked pot one
time they can't have a gun anymore I
don't think that's fair because uh
Hunter had done hard drugs he's
ineligible because someone's committed
to a felony they get out now they can't
get a gun some people have argued well
that's due process and I'm like it's got
to be shorter than that you're right to
vote you're right to keep in bear arms
we shouldn't sentence you to life for it
uh that being said Hunter shouldn't be
charged in my opinion for just buying a
gun though for no reason but disposing
of it in a trash can outside of a school
yeah okay you know maybe we got
something there well he's obviously
guilty of something if that's what
you're doing Amazon
it was his wife I think his wife did it
oh okay so right
uh did she do it or did she go and get
it where did she go uh no no it was a it
was a trash collector who found it okay
yeah okay I'm pretty sure it was uh
Hunter's wife
was it am I my wife
I don't know was he ever married I know
he was sleeping with his brother's wife
oh God we need to start such a weird
story it's just so gross like oh yeah
okay okay it's lover they say love her
it was his uh it was his brother's ex
yeah he started hooking up with
Haley or whatever her name is yeah
that's right it is you know like it's
kind of weird though because like they
have the same last name now because she
married her his brother it was kind of a
weird thing you know all the greatest
stuff that when Hollywood ends up making
movies about that family will be about
Hunter and have nothing to do with Joe
at all all the great entertainment will
come out of honey can we can we do like
who's done nothing no he was perfect dad
apparently
[Music]
can we do like a Game of Thrones show
with the bidens yes oh my God it's
beautiful maybe it'd be compelling you
know like you got an episode where
Hunters just like coked out of his mind
and then it shows him like get up and
then he like straightens his jacket and
the bag falls in the ground and then
like some tourist walks by and sees it
and goes no the Secret Service is like
uh-oh and then if I run like The
Sopranos on HBO no or they they make it
like house of cards with Joe Biden but
it just all keeps happening by accident
nothing actually works out it's just
people are picking up an item it all
keeps happening on accident and
accidentally working out yeah it's
insane like it's it's like accidental
House of Cards Joe Biden trips up the
stairs and then like drops some item
which bounces and then you know like a
marble bounces and then like hits a
button causing a conveyor bounds save
the world all yeah right like all these
really weird things happen he's like
he's sitting in the situation room and
they're like quick we need to respond
sorry not Mr President he falls asleep
and then his face hits the keyboard and
it sends the perfect message you know it
says yes and they're like yes and then
he averts the crisis things like that
and then get Kevin Spacey to play him
because he's a great guy too ew yeah no
he'd be perfect for Biden with all the
sniffing you know what I mean
I think he's done Warden sniffing Kevin
Spacey's on trial right now in the UK
it's very very bad things
he pulled his own version of of the uh
I'm I'm not a pervert I'm Italian he had
one where he's like I'm a flirt with
like horrible stuff innocent until
proven guilty but uh I'm not giving the
guy the benefit of the doubt we'll see
we'll see you know how it goes I'm a
Flirt yeah also a rapist yes
he's like he's like well like after all
the initial claims came I was like look
I'm gay
yeah
what the hell does that have to do with
any of this well now it's probably a
good defense how'd he come out with it
now like this month I mean oh okay
you're good right it should have worked
even then he'll be like I'm cute yeah I
think maybe he'll maybe he'll work in
these arguments where he's like he
couldn't show Pride events and the
behaviors that people do that are
considered normal and say these things
that I was doing were perfectly in line
with what they all do all day every day
at these events nobody cares about it
why am I all of a sudden being targeted
we do live in hell yes that might be an
argument he goes I don't know but I I
did hear that he was like crying or
something yeah
not sure that I care all that much yeah
I mean I don't want to throw the guy uh
you know a safety net or anything but I
mean I I remember a time when when I was
snowboarding in Colorado and if you if
you pulled over on the side of the road
to go to the bathroom and you got caught
you got a sex charge right you could get
like a uh get on a sex registry and now
I mean if you're a q you can just go
piss all over the whole country and you
can get away with it it's just it's just
not I I don't see where all of a sudden
everything is okay yeah so I find it
confusing it's because all the stuff
like it's like when we're talking about
the pride flag everything is about being
oppressed all these groups the one thing
they have in common is they feel they're
oppressed and that's why it's like it's
these degenerate acts that we think of
them as degenerate but then it's like
we're not allowed to do them we don't
have their right so we need to stand up
for those people that don't have the
rights to do all this gross behavior and
that's what we're seeing and it's
completely backwards clown world you
know but it definitely is but that I
mean what you point out about out
there's so many people that have it have
a perspective where they're basing
everything on a
that they're the victim of something
that's something that that's from the
Marxist Playbook the whole point is
power dynamics the whole point is the
person with power is oppressing the
person without power and it all you have
to be able to do is make a compelling
argument that you feel oppressed and
everybody is expected to consent to your
living experience your lived experience
your worldview and you can't have a
society that works like that because
then the incentive is to be oppressed
and to tell everybody about it and we
see the results in society people are
afraid to speak their mind people are
afraid to say things that they believe
people are afraid and they're not afraid
because they have outlandish ideas
they're afraid because the people with
the outlandish ideas are also the ones
that will make us stink and make you
know get people fired or bring you to
the HR department or whatever people
that are unhappy with their lives and
it's all because of that you know the T
teaching people to look at the world
through the dynamic of oppressor and
oppressed and to understand teaching
that them that the position of oppressed
is actually a position of power yeah so
uh did you want to add a point to that I
was just going to say Obama's campaign
was yes we can and it's like no we can't
because of this group or because of this
thing you know it's a fantastic uh plan
for the next Presidential can campaign
no we can no you can't no we can't
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time